la voie est libre merci pauline
effectivement on parle ce matin de
l'emploi avec nos quatre invités laurent
grandguillaume député ps juliette de
hoarau pour la cfdt
et puis catherine vandriesse conseiller
régional l'est républicain dans l'îlot
de la cgpme
alors après l'assemblée nationale qu'il
avait voté à l'unanimité d'ailleurs
c'est une première il me semble pour une
loi qui porte sur le social c'était au
tour du sénat d'examiner à cette semaine
le projet d'expérimentation des
territoires zéro chômeur de longue durée
il a voté lui aussi après l'avoir
légèrement modifié c'est une idée dates
et des carmes en escrime et nous nous la
présenter à ses cinq ans ça consiste en
quoi certainement j'ai rencontré des
responsables de t&d quart-monde ya près
de deux ans ils m'ont soumis l'idée de
mettre en place une expérimentation sur
le chômage longue durée et j'ai rédigé
une proposition de loi dont qui a été
voté et qui j'espère pourra se mettre en
place rapidement l'idée c'est quoi c'est
qu'un chemin longue durée le coût pour
la société c'est environ 15000 euros par
an sas a été vérifié par un économiste
comment jean gadrey qui a fait des
études de sur ce sujet et avec ses 15000
euros par an en fait on pourrait plutôt
financer l'emploi et donc l'idée c'est
que dans des territoires
d'expérimentation dans des territoires
différents
en fait on va expérimenter l'idée selon
laquelle on peut créer des emplois dans
des entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire qui vont être financés par la
réaffectation de ses ressources puisque
la personne va sortir du chômage en
durée et donc les 15000 euros pour être
in finance mon financer un poste en fin
de compte dans cette entreprise et après
l'idée cette entreprise bien les vole de
ses propres ailes
et puis qu'elle puisse répondre à des
besoins utiles sur le territoire sans
rentrer en concurrence avec des
activités existantes parce que le but ce
n'est pas de détruire des emplois qui
existent et donc c'est d'activer des
dépenses qui sont dites passives en fin
de compte c'est à dire de réorienter les
financements donc ça va être essayé
pendant cinq ans moi je pense qu'il faut
regarder un peu plus long qu'un mandat
vous voyez pas ce qu'il faut arrêter de
toujours accroché au mandat ce qu'il
faut c'est regarder à moyen terme et se
dire que dans leur pays
il faudrait qu'on teste des idées
pendant plusieurs années que l'on
regarde si elle fonctionnait cette
marche qu'on les corrige
au fur et à mesure avec les syndicats on
en parlait dans les maisons
professionnelle les élus et après si ça
marche on généralise alors là les
chômeurs de longue durée a pour finir
l'explication serait obligée non ils
seront basés sur mon lit
c'est rare il faut qu'ils soient
volontaires comprenant pas droit
d'évoluer la loi heureusement et donc on
leur proposera un contrat à durée
indéterminée dans des entreprises de
l'économie sociale et solidaire et je
rappelle que un contrat à durée
indéterminée il dépend de la vie
d'entreprise c'est l'entreprise ne
fonctionne pas ça s'arrêtera bien sûr et
on espère bien ça marchera mieux
oui tout à fait et on pourra développer
par exemple des recycleries des
ressourceries je suis allé à prémery par
exemple avec marie-guite dufay dans la
nièvre qui se prépare c'est un
territoire où en 2002 il ya eu 700
suppressions d'emplois parce que
l'industrie a fermé ses portes et donc
dans ce territoire il est parfaitement
frappé par le chômage endurées par
exemple alors les biens correspondants
en haïti sont essayés saison difficile
pour vous de nico est ce que d'autres
députés c'est ce que cela veut dire
gagner le smic avec parfois des
conditions de travail difficiles son
projet est il seulement une utopie dans
laquelle ils semblent s'accrocher mais
d'abord moi même j'ai à travailler bien
évidemment sur des emplois au smic comme
tout le monde quand on commence j'ai mis
des boîtes de conserve en des rayons
j'ai vendu du carrelage à leroy merlin à
quétigny j'ai fait plein de petits
boulots au départ avant de pouvoir
passer des concours ou en tout cas
profession c'est d'être mal étape donc
c'est une étape c'est pas on n'y pas que
la personne va bien sûr être payés au
smic toute sa vie l'idée c'est que c'est
pour commencer en fin de compte pour que
l'entreprise est bien elles puissent
embaucher des personnes au smic démarrer
l'activité et puis si elle croit même
elle pourra bien sûr augmenter leur
salaire était en sorte que lé plus de
moyens financiers bien sûr le but c'est
pas qu'elle soit payée au smic toute
leur vie un amoureux sur cette
initiative pour vous cette des emplois
aidés ou c'est une ça peut être une
solution non écoutez nous on se félicite
de l'initiative déjà puisque le chômage
de longue durée est une est un cancer
pour le pays donc effectivement là la
démarche portée par le rang et est
aujourd'hui le projet de loi adopté en
fin de compte et oui il était de voir
passe de l'être parce qu'il a du sens
quand on regarde uniquement au niveau
des coûts c'est vrai que quinze mille
euros de coût pour la société sur un
chômeur de longue durée contre
investissent dans une entreprise pour
qu'elles puissent embaucher le chauffeur
s'il tentait de l'activité je remets
toujours ça en parallèle ça a du sens
moi ce qui me fait peur dans ce projet
de loi c'est qu'effectivement les
entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire sont souvent en concurrence
d'entreprises classiques qui eux
n'auront pas ses aides gens regardaient
dans le volet et dans le projet doit
présenter on parlait paysagiste
parler de nettoyage il ya plein
d'entreprise des pme locales qui font du
paysagiste qu'ils font et si
l'entreprise qui est issu de l'économie
sociale et solidaire arrive à lui faire
concurrence avec un taux de charge
complètement amenuisée par rapport à la
pme standard on va créer une concurrence
déloyale donc attention à ça c'est c'est
le seul bémol que je vais pouvoir mettre
sur le projet doit par contre
l'initiative
je m'en félicite tout ce qui sera bon
pour l'emploi et les chômeurs de longue
durée sera bon pour l'économie sera bon
pour le pouvoir d'achat des français et
ce sera bon aussi pour leur consommation
ici sur place
j'adore les plats celle des
technosciences félicite de ce projet
mais nous restons toujours vigilants
c'est évidemment donc non on y voit un
côté favorable de fait que ça soit une
expérimentation déjà donc voilà qu'on
puisse veiller à ce qu'ils aient pas de
de concurrence qui est pas un effet
négatif
par contre l'avantagé on y voit
effectivement on est sur du chômeur de
longue durée c'est retour à un petit peu
de dignité aussi parce que voilà on
parle pas de d'un chômage d'une période
d'un mois ou deux enfin voilà donc durer
ça veut dire des honorables voix
largement c'est compliqué ça passe par
là par contre nous donne nos
interrogations c'est entre autres c'est
on n'a pas vu dans le texte le un
tremplin vers les envers les emplois
classique
c est la phase qu'il n'ya interviendrait
après si tout fonctionne voilà ce texte
a été voté à l'unanimité
on est relativement d'accord autour
natale donc il faut le dire aussi
mais je rejoins non mais c'est important
sont heureusement je voulais dit je vais
parler la voiture france là on a besoin
de tout notre passage et nous soyons un
peu plus en confiance donc ces
dispositions elle est intéressante avec
laser qu'à donner des tuyaux évidemment
de la concurrence avec l'économie non
sociale et solidaire et là on est sur
les activités c'est vraiment son fils de
lauwe du rasoir à la différence il ya
aussi d'autres manières et là j'aimerais
voir la position de ce grand guillaume
et un rapport qui sortirait très peu de
temps sur le choc de compétitivité du
passage aux 37 heures en france qui
permettra de gagner trois points de pib
et les 35 heures à la fonction publique
35 heures et fonction publique appliquée
aujourd'hui ses 570 millions d'euros
d'économies de la fonction publique donc
il ya d'autres solutions ça en plein
juste travailler un peu plus
alors est ce qu'on n'en ont pas
le ca justement durée du travail contrat
de travail ou la la ça c'est cerveau
thani pour répondre j'étais favorable à
la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires contre la suppression
exemple et tour est en lien avec ce
court autant je ne suis pas pour avoir
des débats hydraulique
en gros on l'a vu sur des boutons et ça
produit des effets car il faut passer à
37 heures à 32 heures à 35,1 en fait il
faut prendre en compte les réalités dans
les territoires des personnes des
entreprises jour un cadre légal
bien évidemment une durée du travail
c'est normal mesure illégale c'est c'est
logique il faudrait qu'elle serait
appliquée après les jo je vois une fois
de la négociation de la souplesse des
entreprises en fait et il y en a déjà
mais il en faudrait plus avec les
acteurs des expériences arrivé avec la
réforme du code du travail
j'espère en tout cas que roncq on va
donner plus de liberté aux partenaires
sociaux
en fait dans les territoires pour
négocier voilà pour redonner du souffle
en fin de compte c'est pas depuis paris
qu'on a décidé de tout dans tous les
territoires
la france n'est pas un pays qui va se
séparer se fracturer par des
régionalismes on a de la marge de
manoeuvre pour donner d'énergie notre
territoire donc il faut le faudrait
cette énergie à nos partenaires sociaux
leur faire confiance
oui je vois ça saoule sont en tête sous
tente et qu'on arrive à aujourd'hui
arrêter le vieux clivage salary
entreprises et que ce partenariat les
partenaires sociaux s'entendre sur des
projets qui créeront de l'emploi
écriront de la richesse parce que je ne
faut pas voir compte de ce qu'il faut
créer de la richesse dans le pays
il faut ancrer etc trichet sera mieux
redistribuer concernant le contrat de
travail évidemment nous sommes des
fervents et ferment demandeurs de la
simplification du code du travail de la
flexibilité du contrat de travail
aujourd'hui on peut plus imaginer avoir
un emploi qui soit le même pendant 40
ans dans le pays
il faut que demain nos salariés de
demain imagine bien que leur emploi va
changer quatre cinq fois dans leur
carrière et qu'on y soit prêt il faut
qu'une entreprise qui est aujourd'hui la
possibilité d'embaucher un salarié parce
qu'elle a du travail là maintenant n'ai
pas peur de le prendre et refuse
peut-être le travail parce qu'elle sait
qu'elle pourra s'en séparer demain s'ils
appuient le travail
c'est ça la qui va créer de l'emploi
c'est un peu compliqué à entendre aussi
propre garde à vue que c'était une ligne
jaune assez c'est à dire le renverser
oui non oui comprenez bien alors pour
autant on est pour les réformes
j'ai pas pu en parler tout à l'heure on
trouve sur le statut des apprentis ou là
on dit oui il ya des choses à faire donc
sur ce type de contrats l'un sur jaillir
le contrat de droit commun ça va être
compliqué ça va être compliqué parce que
vous ne pourrez pas toucher la
protection des salariés c'est pas
possible
la flexibilité elle est déjà possible
les déjà envisageable avec des accords
d'entreprise
donc pourquoi aller toucher quelque
chose qui finalement de contrat de
travail reprend des règles convenues
entre l'employeur et le salarié
voilà je suis d'accord sur la
simplification du code parce que c'est
pas à la portée de tout le monde
code du travail et maintenant sans cela
uniquement mais pas simplifié pour
supprimer des droits et des prononcer
tandis qu'elle avait des droits c'est de
word d'anticiper de monde du travail
demain différemment c'est pas parce
qu'on aura un contrat tu seras moins
protégés quand on prend on accède à l'
embauche que ce sera pas pérenne pour
l'emploi on va créer de l'emploi par
cette mesure
quand on regarde une mesure qui a été
prise récemment sur l'augmentation du
seuil du conte travail à temps partiel
ça c'est est destructeur d'emplois
on passe à 25 heures minimum celui qui a
aujourd'hui besoin de 15 heures dans son
entreprise il va pas embaucher 25 heures
donc au lieu de 30 15 heures mais prend
plus rien et c'est comme ça donc toutes
ces mesures qui rigidifie notre code du
travail qui rendent aujourd'hui
complètement absurde l'embauché d'un
salarié pour un chef d'entreprise parce
que quand il est devant son cdi d'imagés
que des risques chez que des risques
dans le cdi donc la science est par
ailleurs livré sa normale non mais c'est
pas aussi simple que ça j'ai que des
risques et en plus la flexibilité sur le
temps de travail quand j'ai besoin de 10
15 heures qui quand même apporte une
certaine rémunération salariés qui
veulent occuper ce poste il aura quand
même 10 15 heures il faut pas se passer
de toutes les pistes qui pourront
relancer l'emploi toutes les pistes et
en se sclérosent ans derrière des choses
d'un autre temps mais on n'y arrivera
pas grande gueule et catherine
effectivement confrontées toutes les
idées le croire et réussir à converger
collectivement vers des solutions pour
les citoyens et moi j'invite tous ceux
qui nous regardent à aller voir ce
qu'est médical tort qu en fait qui a été
créée par amazon
c'est une en gros une agence d'intérim
international où chacun dans le monde
peut aller travailler pour amazon et
produire une
les stations c'est en gros la fin du
salariat c'est la fin des protections
c'est le prolétariat du 21e siècle
ouvriers et bien moi je crois que la
france dans son modèle elle peut à la
fois concilier la protection pour les
personnes comme l'a fait le con
sommation de la résistance d'ailleurs et
en même temps la souplesse dans les
entreprises c'est ça qu'il faut il faut
trouver la bonne voie mais par le débat
par le respect ils vont arrêter je crois
de tours penser que celui qui en face
qu'il a tort et qu'on a la raison à nos
soldats entrent les eaux se retirent
en face les télés 5e vont sentir qu'il
ya on est dans un climat aujourd'hui
constructive en tout cas dans les
restaurants tous les quatre mais
simplement pour les avis vous madame
vous savez benoît raison dans beaucoup
de tpe pme serge ou par des entreprises
de moins de 20 salariés et ans qui est
quand même la large majorité des
entreprises
on est en pression sur le temps de
travail et comme on n'est pas dans une
situation on n'a nulle envie et le
risque derrière et la possibilité par un
contrat à temps partiel d'embauché la
pression se fait sur qui elle se fait
sur les salariés qui sont présents les
15 heures dans par benoît il va bien
falloir les à partir parce qu'on va
chercher des parts de marché et de la
valeur ajoutée qui doit être un mot
qu'on doit prononcer pourcentage par
pourcentage donc dans ce scénario la
très classique et bah qu'est ce qu'on
fait on en a tous nous de remettre un
petit coup de plus on trouve des
systèmes de récupération d'heures c'est
comme ça que mon du travail fonctionne
aujourd'hui et on doit pouvoir trouver
d'autres solutions plus innovantes
merci beaucoup merci à tous les cas
d'avoir participé à ce débat il y aurait
encore beaucoup de choses à dire on peut
préciser quand il y aura un séminaire
sur la question du plan d'urgence à la
fin du mois entre les partenaires
sociaux pour l'emploi et les présidents
de région également
alors je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
voir ou revoir cette émission sur notre
site internet bourgogne point france en
point fr la semaine prochaine c'est
andré billardon qui sera l'invité de la
voie est libre
ancien député ancien ministre ancien
président du conseil régional andré
billardon vient de quitter son poste de
maire du creusot qu'il occupait depuis
21 pour l'heure c'est le 12/13 qui se
poursuit avec l'actualité nationale et
internationale très bonne après midi
merci